so I understand that Julia has you saved
in her phone as Batman
I freeze I'm Batman
yeah that's gonna change
Michael Keaton's coming back could you
ever Dawn the suit again well I think
there'd be a protest on you I think
there would be a oh yes there it
actually would be a protest but I think
that there's a real uh a calling for
once you know like in about 30 years
when I'm sort of even smaller
okay so if you're Batman in her phone
what's Brad Pitt in your
I
had to post the picture of you and them
all because it took my breath away
George oh I'm all in that green dress
she uh she has uh pretty nice taste yeah
she really does look at Julia and then I
mean yeah I mean Julia was being honored
it was like the Oscar it was like
it was like Oscars what is that
nightlife it was a beautiful night come
on in here miss Julie you want to come
in with us I should be able to say nice
things about her which I don't like to
do are you talking about the other night
yes it's a nice guy I don't want to talk
about it you're going to start to cry I
don't want you to cry but I do want you
to talk about what that means you you've
been in a room full of of people like
that at the Oscars in places where
you've been like where you you know
you've been honored right
what life yeah it was it was it was well
I can tell you the truth she told me she
didn't like most of those people
it was really beautiful it was really
really special and friends like Tilda
and everybody else was also in there it
was really fun yeah and you did a
beautiful speech and now she's cheating
by the way she's wearing she's wearing
heels I'm not that well I mean this is a
wow
let's see yeah yeah yeah
but do you see what I'm doing too I'm
doing this oh that's nice of you the
moment that Diana Ross walks up what is
that we were texting about it the next
day I mean that's like that's the next
level she's telling us you watch like
those great Motown documentaries and you
feel like they were the 1930s
and there she's standing there and she
doesn't look like she's aged a day and
her voice she was amazing hasn't changed
it was magical it really was it was
great
[Music]